en plein milieu du plat pays de gosse
difficile de rater mode et nathalie avec
leurs tee shirt orange pendant neuf
jours elle traverse leur et loire à vélo
pour faire connaître l' ong vision du
monde et soutenir une action en
particulier on a axé sur l'hygiène des
filles au vietnam donc ce projet aide
800 800 filles notamment dans
l'amélioration des conditions de vie des
d'hygiène des toilettes et puis tout ce
qui est
aussi jeune intime tout ça sur leur
cagnotte en ligne elles ont déjà reçu
plus de 2000 euros alors qu'elle n'en
espérais que 1500 et au gré diplômes et
des rencontres et on finance un projet
pour les filles au vietnam est pas très
gentil autres ses habitants leur foute
aussi des dons comme ici à elie combret
les gens sont super sympas et c'est vrai
que ça interpelle de voir un vélo avec
une remorque jaune avec vision du monde
dessus les drapeaux donc les gens
viennent spontanément nous voir et
viennent nous demander ce que l'on fait
mais leur projet ne s'arrête pas là pour
chaque euro récolté elle ramasse aussi
un déchet une canette way écrasé
5 ans et 56 56 déchets récoltés depuis
le début de la journée et au temps
d'arrêt c'est un effort parce qu'on se
dit on nettoie on ramasse ça c'est plus
propre que de voir un plastique à
l'entrée des villes à la sortie des
villes des vilains un peu plus
importante menace est là en armes a subi
là sur les petites routes de campagne
c'est vraiment ses propres il faut à la
remorque pleine ou trop lourdes elle la
vit dans des poubelles publiques ou chez
des connaissances regarde ce qu'on a
récolté on a dormi à phraser depuis
phrasé en passant par est liée à la mode
et nathalie s'était fixé 508 kilomètres
à parcourir et un millier de déchets à
ramasser mais avec le succès de la
cagnotte elle compte d'ores et déjà
organisé un autre périple à vélo